istres la parole à monsieur julie aubert
pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame le garde des sceaux
madame le ministre suite à l'évasion
d'un criminel qui a provoqué profiter
d'une homonymie pour bénéficier d'une
permission de sortie à la place d'un
codétenu j'ai visité de manière inopinée
vendredi dernier la prison du pontet et
j ai rencontré rencontrer son personnel
alors la manière dont il s'est évadé
pour le moins incongrue il n'en reste
pas moins que le problème c'est celui du
greffe de cette prison avec un trait
bluff de faibles taux d'expérimentation
puisque le pdt le dernier en poste
le premier le plus ancien en poste avait
un an d'ancienneté et l'évasion on peut
sembler anecdotique mais en réalité elle
est la dernière d'une longue liste
d'évasion pas moins de 13 au cours des
trois derniers mois à nîmes un détenu
s'est évadé quelques heures à rio et à
saint brieuc les détenus ont profité
d'une permission de sortie
argentan c'est au cours des obsèques ne
sont pas pas que le détenu a mis les
voiles
annoncé tout simplement dans la fasnet
du chu à angers c'est une évasion à
l'aide d'un drap a grenoble il a profité
d'une comparaison d'une comparution
devant le juge pour filer à l anglaise à
fois c'est une évasion digne d'une série
télé ils sont passés par les faux
plafonds et les canalisations de la
prison à fresnes le détenu a profité
d'un tournoi de boxe à besançon d'une
sortie en vtt à moulins le prisonnier
s'est même offert le luxe de prévenir
les surveillants avant de se faire la
belle et amiens les détenus aussi et les
barreaux de leur fenêtre ils ont utilisé
les câbles anti-évasion pour s'évader
alors je sais vous allez me fusiller du
regard vous allez gronder l'opposition
telle une maîtresse d'école
vous allez faire vos effets de manche
nous avons l'habitude vous allez me
répondre avec votre plan de sécurisation
votre 1,3 million d'euros 1 800 millions
d'euros
mais madame le ministre il ya une
journée de une journée syndicale le 26
novembre
que disent les syndicats que pour tout
pour tous vous leur avez proposé 8 euros
nets mensuels d'augmentation de leurs
indemnités est ce que c'est ça que vous
appelez l'indépendance de la justice
il ne suffit pas d'être une ancienne
indépendantistes pour faire garantir
pour garantir l'indépendance de la
justice
alors après avoir démissionné face à la
délinquance allez vous démissionner tout
coup merci monsieur robert la parole et
à madame la garde des sceaux ministre de
la justice monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député julien aubert je ne
suis pas persuadé que cette attitude de
la rambo soit tout à fait adapté aux
sujets que vous avez essayé d'aborder
vous ne pensez quand même pas effrayer
qui que ce soit ici
simplement il ya eu une erreur vraiment
regrettable à la prison du pontet
puisque cette homonymie a permis que
sorte un détenu en permission nous avons
vérifié l'erreur et dans lordonnance de
permission de sortie et cela a entraîné
une erreur dans le greffe le parquet on
a été avisé immédiatement ce qui a
permis évidemment d'engager les
recherches nous avons également
introduit une enquête administrative
pour voir à quel niveau cette erreur
peut être détecté par ce que nous
améliorons le dispositif de suivi et de
vérification et bien entendu surtout
nous généralisant le logiciel gîte que
vous avez évité de mentionner que nous
avons installé l'année dernière et qui
permettra ce double contrôle
nous en avons les moyens oui nous le
généralisant sur l'ensemble du
territoire
il vous aurait fallu beaucoup plus une
question d'actualité pour citer le
nombre d'exemples dramatique et
malheureux d'évasion sous le précédent
quinquennat je vais pas vous rappeler je
vais pas vous rappeler malheureusement
la libération d'un
ce violeur en octobre 2008 je vais pas
vous rappeler non plus l'évasion d'un
important trafiquants de drogue
en 2011 je vais vous rappeler simplement
que le taux d'évasion sous l'ancien
quinquennat était de 0 61 %
il est sous ce quinquennat de 0,47 pour
cent donc effectivement nous pourrions
vous expliquer deux ou trois choses mais
ce sont des choses que nous prenons au
sérieux que nous n'avons jamais exploité
lorsque nous étions dans l'opposition
parce que nous avons du respect pour les
citoyens de ce pays et nous savons
surtout une haute conscience de notre
responsabilité pour améliorer la
protection et la sécurité des français
merci madame la ministre
la parole table